qu'est-ce qu'il a aux yeux forest weaker
vous avez remarqué que son œil gauche il
est tout le temps à moitié fermé oui un
peu comme moi mais moi j'ai un orgelet
moi ça va passer vite s'il vous plaît
forest weaker il a pas un orgelet il a
un ptosis le seul point commun entre les
deux c'est qu'en fait c'est pas un
problème d'œil c'est un problème de
paupière pour bouger nos paupières on a
des muscles parmi ces muscles il y en a
un qui s'appelle le releveur de la
paupière supérieure je crois que vu son
nom son rôle est assez clair quand on a
un ptosis comme forest setaker il y a un
problème au niveau de ce muscle un
problème qui l'empêche de relever
complètement la paupière supérieure
parce qu'il est trop faible parce qu'il
s'est un petit peu décroché et cetera et
cetera ça peut être de naissance ou
après un accident ou après une opération
ça peut être des deux côtés ou d'un seul
comme forest weaker et suivant la cause
ça peut s'opérer soit parce que ça gêne
au niveau esthétique soit parce que ça
perturbe la vision par exemple mais
c'est pas du tout obligé forest weaker
par exemple il a choisi de pas le faire
et il y a rien à dire là-dessus